House Democrats are debating whether the
Muller report gives them enough evidence
to start impeachment hearings against
President Trump CBS News legal analyst
Jonathan Turley testified before
Congress on the legal standards of
impeachment during the Clinton
proceedings in 1998 he is a
constitutional law professor at George
Washington University and we know that
he's read the full mullet for my sins
thank you and it is a very serious
report put together let's talk about the
Constitution
article 2 section 4 of the Constitution
sets the bar for impeachment at high
crimes and misdemeanors do we know from
the Muller report if the president
reached that point we don't but there
are tantalizing indications that he may
have this comes down to a question of
interpretation if you actually look at
the article 1 of the impeachment of
Richard Nixon it has many of the items
that Muller combed out of his
investigation things like suggesting to
witnesses that they might be pardoned or
getting given commutations giving false
statements or deceiving the public all
these things that are in the Mahler
report actually were part of the Nixon
impeachment but it comes down to a
question of intent and that's the
difficulty here but yeah well president
Trumbo says that he would turn to the
Supreme Court to to follow up on
impeachment can he do that no he can't
adjust that he'll lose in the heartbeat
I mean it's it's entirely frivolous the
the framers gave this matter to Congress
and there's nothing really for them to
review or to intervene on in that type
of action it could delay things but the
result is all but serviced it only falls
on Congress and today that's right for
impeach correct speaking of the framers
Franklin said that impeachment was when
a president rendered himself obnoxious
which never got into the final document
but the 55 men who were there the
delegates what do you think they would
think do they would they think that the
behavior mentioned in the malla report
was sufficient for impeachment
I think the framers would be appalled by
most of what they see by Congress or the
president that's why I feel more
comfortable in the 18th century but the
fact is that the framers did give some
room at the elbows for for Congress
Congress actually can
teach someone for a non-crime but it's
also important for people to recognize
molar found a number of non criminal
motives by President Trump that works to
his advantage
on issues like the Trump Tower even the
firing attempt to fire Muller he found
these non criminal reasons for doing
what he did but you know this is a
400-page tale of self-inflicted wounds
and the president's writing a sequel you
know by saying that that he never told
Don began to fire Muller he's creating a
very important factual dispute that
Congress has no choice but to
investigate and if he's lying that was
part of the first article of impeachment
against Richard Nixon oh you mean this
subsequent tweet that the president just
said where he said he didn't do that
yeah if Congress concludes that the
president is lying about the underlying
facts of impeachment that actually can
become a matter for them to consider for
impeachment some would call that a
self-inflicted wound yes and repeated
one yeah okay all right thank you very
much always early about this time oh
yeah you know your stuff